Le Burkina Faso est l'une des dix nations
les plus pauvres du monde.
Peu de touristes
y viennent pourtant,
il a besoin de l'économie
générée par cette activité.
L'ancienne Haute-Volta
offre cependant de nombreux atouts,
dont le plus emblématique
est un tourisme discret.
Sortir des sentiers battus,
aller là où les autres ne vont pas,
voir des villages authentiques,
y apprécier la culture,
les traditions africaines
et l'extrême gentillesse de la population
sont les choix d'une dizaine de Français
qui a choisi de vivre un séjour
en camping authentique et solidaire
avec les habitants.
Les sept premiers sont de la même famille,
dont trois sœurs.
Avec eux, Patrice et Maggy.
Ce petit groupe est arrivé
à Ouagadougou la capitale.
Sans attendre pour faire le tour du pays,
ils ont embarqué à bord du minibus
qui sera leur seul moyen
de transport pour leur séjour.
C'est Jean-Pierre et son épouse Dani
qui ont initié le reste du groupe
aux vacances équitables.
Ils devront d'abord
se rendre à Bobo-Dioulasso,
au sud-est du pays,
sept heures de trajet minimum.
Avant de prendre la route,
ils ont prévu de visiter Keoogo,
une association créée en 2005
qui aide des enfants en difficulté de vie.
Ils sont reçus par Patrice,
l'un des éducateurs spécialisés.
La pauvreté et l'effondrement des
structures familiales et communautaires,
et parfois celle des traditions
sont en partie
responsables
de l'abandon de ces enfants.
Je suis psychologue,
responsable psychosocial
au niveau de l'association Keoogo.
On travaille
exclusivement dans la rue
pour voir un peu
comment assister les enfants qui y vivent,
les écouter,
voir quels sont leurs besoins
et essayer de trouver des réponses.
Parfois, nous recevons
des enfants qui nous sont référés
par les différents commissariats de police
ou les brigades de gendarmerie,
pour les mineurs
en conflit avec la loi
ou bien des enfants
qui en font la demande,
de venir dans un centre pour être préparés
pour la réinsertion familiale définitive.
Aujourd'hui, c'est samedi
et l'administration ne travaille pas,
mais il y a un service
de permanence avec les enfants.
On pourra éventuellement voir avec eux
si on peut échanger avec les enfants
et visiter les locaux aussi.
L'une des voitures
de l'association va en mission,
direction le centre
d'accueil destiné aux jeunes filles.
Il est implanté dans les faubourgs,
loin des tentations de la ville.
L'an passé,
il y avait 8000 garçons et 400 filles
recensés comme enfants
des rues à Ouagadougou.
Adelaïde Sowado,
est responsable psychosociale.
Elle sait que les filles sont les plus
exposées bien que peu nombreuses.
Prostitution, sida, coups
et blessures, séquestrations.
Depuis un certain temps, on voit qu'il y a
une augmentation de ce phénomène.
De plus en plus des enfants
viennent en rue pour plusieurs raisons.
Il y a la pauvreté
généralisée que nous connaissons.
Il y a des familles entières qui
sont pauvres et n'arrivent même pas
à subvenir à leurs besoins,
ni assurer le repas quotidien.
Cela fait que les enfants
viennent en rue à la recherche du travail,
à la recherche de la pitance
pour pouvoir subvenir à leurs besoins.
C'est pareil
pour les filles aussi.
Elles viennent en ville
à la recherche du travail.
Au centre
Pan-bila la petite force,
un millier de jeunes filles
est passée dans ce sanctuaire.
Une sur deux
a retrouvé une vie sociale normale.
Pour les autres...
Ça va ?
Ici,
c'est le Centre Pan-bila deux.
Actuellement,
je sais qu'il y a quinze filles.
Combien de bébés ?
Combien sont enceintes ?
Il y en a trois.
Si trois sont enceintes, ça fait douze
filles mères et une qui est partie.
Treize enfants.
Oui, il y a une qui a des jumelles
et une qui est partie pour accoucher.
Sa principale action est d'écouter et
conseiller ces filles en souffrance.
Asseyez-vous !
Ça va bien ?
- Ça va.
Bien, bien ?
Je fais le bien là
pour toi et ton enfant.
C'est comme si les enfants aussi
se trouvaient dans la même situation.
Je suis en devoir de t'aider.
C'est compris ?
C'est notre devoir,
c'est notre association qui fait cela.
Aider n'importe quel fille ou garçon
qui se trouverait dans une situation,
quel que soit
ton pays d'origine.
Les parcours de ces jeunes filles
ressemblent à celui de Lucienne.
La plupart des filles qui sont ici,
sont totalement prises en charge,
sur le plan alimentaire, vestimentaire,
sanitaire, sur tous les plans.
Le manque d'argent ralentit
un certain nombre d'activités.
Par exemple le retour en famille,
les renouements, les médiations,
les recherches de paternité.
Il faut des sorties vers les villages,
vers les parents, vers les structures,
donc ça nécessite un certain nombre
de moyens humains,
matériels et financiers.
Retour au centre des garçons,
visités par notre groupe.
Ils ont apporté avec eux
des objets utiles.
La peinture doit être dans des sacs,
on va regarder.
Merci beaucoup.
Je leur donne tout ça.
Voici quelques peintures,
mais il y en a d'autres dans les sacs.
On est un peu couac
c'est le cas de le dire.
Ce qu'on amène ou ce qu'on fait,
est très peu
mais ça leur fait plaisir.
Nous sommes heureux
de les avoir rencontrés
et d'avoir participé
à quelque chose de concret
avec des gens
qui s'occupe d'eux toute l'année.
Au revoir et bon courage.
Bonne santé !
C'est avec cette première expérience
que le groupe prend la route
à bord du minibus, direction
Bobo-Dioulasso, à 370 kilomètres.
Il est temps d'installer
le premier bivouac.
Tu es lourde !
J'ai eu le virus de l'Afrique,
ça remonte déjà
à pas loin
d'une trentaine d'années.
J'ai eu l'opportunité
de suivre avec des amis de Dakar
et j'ai pris goût au bivouac.
J'ai pris goût
à ce type d'aventure
avec des gens qui ne vivent pas
au même rythme que nous.
C'est l'authenticité,
c'est la simplicité.
Au fil des années, je me suis senti
en Afrique, un peu comme chez moi.
Nous qui sommes des nantis
voulons toujours plus.
Par contre eux,
ils se contentent de ce qu'ils ont.
On a choisi ce type de voyage
pour être au plus près des gens,
pour aller dans les villages,
pour les rencontrer,
pour avoir des guides locaux,
pour faire connaissance
tout simplement de leurs cultures,
de leurs traditions, de leur religion.
C'est différent
de lorsque tu fais des voyages
dans des hôtels trois étoiles,
ce n'est pas ce qu'on recherche.
Tu n'as pas ce contact
avec la population.
Tu vois des choses ici
que tu ne vois pas en ville et dans
des voyages organisés plus luxueux,
avec des structures
beaucoup plus abouties.
C'est un peu l'aventure pour nous
et ça nous plaît.
Il est entrain
de faire ses comptes.
Les restaurants du cœur.
En Afrique, on boit de la bière
alors qu'on n'en boit jamais
et on mange de la soupe
alors qu'on n'en mange jamais.
C'est Alassane, le cuistot,
qui prépare les repas.
Ça a été extrêmement bruyant,
non pas à cause des camions
mais à cause de cet individu
qui a ronflé toute la nuit.
Dans une petite tente,
c'est très dur.
Très bien, un petit peu mouvementé
l'avant nuit,
mais après
ça s'est très bien passé.
Rustique, mais très agréable
et puis la découverte
des gens
qu'on ne connaissait pas.
L'observation des préparatifs
aux 12 ou 13 jours qui vont suivre,
c'est assez sympathique.
Trois, quatre, cinq, six.
- Il ne faut pas mélanger.
Ce ne sont que des enfants.
Moi je voudrais vider un sac
et le garder avec moi.
D'accord.
Ce sont des vêtements
qu'on a récupérés dans notre famille.
- Chez des amis qui ont eu des enfants.
Juste la famille,
nos enfants et petits enfants.
Depuis qu'on sait qu'on part, on récolte
à droite, à gauche des vêtements.
On fait ça
chaque fois qu'on vient.
Ce sont les enfants
qui m'émeuvent le plus.
Je crois que
je les emmènerai avec moi.
Hier, j'ai vu un petit,
j'ai des chaussures de bébé,
mais elles étaient là-haut sur le camion
et le petit avait des chiffons
autour des pieds parce qu'il avait un pied
blessé, ça me fait mal au cœur.
C'est une goutte d'eau
dans l'océan
mais si tous les touristes faisaient
une toute petite chose comme ça,
je trouve que ça serait bien,
c'est tellement peu.
Des gens viennent et n'y pensent pas et
d'autres les mains vides et ça,
je n'arrive pas
à le comprendre.
Chacun fait comme il peut.
On avait droit à 50 kilos.
On a 20 kilogrammes pour nous
et 30 kilogrammes à donner.
On a des affaires d'école,
des médicaments.
Il faut tout regrouper aussi.
Par contre, on ne voudrait pas créer des
histoires entre eux, comme des bagarres
Hier, on a compris, on donne à l'adulte
et plus aux enfants.
Ça fait trop de problèmes.
Le voyage se poursuit encore plus au sud,
vers Banfora.
Il fait très chaud, 40 dégrés.
C'est Moumouni, le guide chauffeur,
qui assure la conduite.
Pour répondre
à la demande des voyageurs,
le minibus fait halte
dans un petit village.
Les femmes dorment avec les enfants.
Une seule femme par case.
Oui.
Un mari
pour plusieurs femmes ?
Oui, ça arrive souvent.
Il choisit.
Ça !
Qui en veut ?
Oui.
Débrouillez-vous !
Tu veux danser ?
Je ne sais pas si ça va lui servir
tout ça, regarde.
Un petit ciseau pour couper les ongles.
Un tournevis,
c'est la boîte à outils minuscule.
Tu veux ?
C'est pour toi.
Les enfants
jouent avec le grand-père.
Puisque ses habits sont un peu déchirés,
ils lui ont dit d'aller s'échanger.
Il n'est pas
présentable comme ça.
Au village, les hommes
terminent la récolte du coton.
Le Burkina Faso est parmi les plus
importants producteurs africains.
Le coton est pour beaucoup
la seule source de revenus.
Il est gourmand, il use les sols et laisse
peu de place aux autres plantations.
Merci beaucoup.
Ce n'est pas blanc, mais vert.
Il y a marqué mi-mai, mi-juillet,
mais ici, avec le soleil et l'eau,
tu peux les planter quand tu veux,
et trois semaines, ça pousse.
Je sers tout le monde.
Comme vous le constatez,
on a une crevaison,
on a dû changer la roue,
mais tout va bien pour le moment.
Plus le groupe descend vers le sud,
plus il s'éloigne des zones désertiques
et brûlantes et plus
les paysages changent.
La région de Ban-foras
est l'une des plus verdoyantes du pays
et est aussi l'une
des plus arrosées.
L'occasion d'une halte fraîcheur
très appréciée après cinq heures de piste.
J'ai choisi ce type de voyage
parce que ce que j'aime,
c'est aller près des populations,
près des gens,
rentrer dans les villages,
rencontrer les enfants
et comprendre comment
ils vivent dans ce pays
par rapport à chez nous où tout nous
semble si facile.
Ce qui me ferait peur
que ce soit loupé
de la part des organisateurs,
c'est de ne pas s'arrêter assez souvent
dans des endroits
un peu perdus.
S'arrêter tout le temps aux mêmes
endroits, dans les grandes villes.
Les villes où on s'arrête,
on voit des touristes et du monde,
et on leur offre
quelque chose.
Alors qu'à côté, il y a des petits
villages où personne ne va jamais.
C'est ça qui me gêne.
Je pense que travailler sur place,
c'est plus intéressant
au lieu
des opérateurs extérieurs.
J'ai déjà fait des voyages ailleurs
avec des opérateurs vers l'extérieur.
C'est du grand circuit, c'est tout fait,
préparé à l'avance, des hôtels.
Alors que là on est plus,
je ne dirai pas que c'est l'aventure,
ce serait exagéré de dire ça,
mais c'est plus inaccoutumé pour nous.
C'est reposant dans la mesure où
on est habitués à se presser
pour que les choses
soient faites à l'heure.
Nous n'avons aucun mouvement,
ça c'est agréable.
Le fait que les gens dans les voyages
comme ça apportent des choses
pour soulager
un peu la misère.
Je l'ai fait très longtemps à Madagascar,
j'apportais beaucoup de médicaments.
Des amis médecins
qui me les donnaient.
J'ai fait des d'affaires
avec beaucoup aussi.
On s'encombre
beaucoup moins maintenant.
On voit que d'autres gens,
le font et ça fait plaisir.
Je ne sais pas si ça va servir
à beaucoup mais on fait ce qu'on peut.
Chacun a repris des forces
aux cascades de Ban-foras.
Si au nord, le coton est roi,
ici c'est la canne à sucre qui règne.
Le groupe à un rendez-vous de poids
sur le lac Tengrele,
à une vingtaine de kilomètres.
Ce lac naturel
héberge depuis toujours des hippopotames.
Ils sont une centaine
et avec un peu de chance
et de la patience,
le spectacle est grandiose.
Il y a cinq jours
que le groupe est sur la route.
Le soir, au campement,
chacun a trouvé sa place.
Les nuits
se passent très bien.
Il fait plus frais le matin par rapport
aux deux ou trois premières nuits.
On survit,
il faut bien survivre.
Au début, c'était le bazar,
regarde maintenant, on a tout trouvé.
Comme d'habitude,
ce sont les femmes qui font la lessive,
les hommes qui installent
de quoi dormir correctement.
La nuit, il fait froid
et le matin, il caille.
Il fait froid le matin.
Ce matin, ce sont 218 kilomètres qu'il
faudra parcourir pour rejoindre Gaoual,
en pays Lobi,
tout au sud du pays.
La frontière avec la Côte d'Ivoire
est toute proche.
Elle accueillait de nombreux Burkinabé
venus y chercher fortune.
Les troubles de ces dernières années
les ont incités à revenir au pays,
augmentant la démographie
de façon significative.
Avant d'arriver à Gaoual,
Jean-Pierre et Dany,
avec l'accord du groupe, ont souhaité
faire un arrêt dans un dispensaire.
Nous vous apportons des lunettes
et un peu de médicaments
que nous avons
récupérés chez nous.
On peut rentrer ?
Oui, c'est vraiment gentil.
Un peu surprise par cette venue
et Aimé Claire Niki Emma les accueille.
Elle est infirmière
dans ce dispensaire depuis un an.
Il y a beaucoup
d'antidouleurs pour soulager.
C'est tellement gentil,
merci beaucoup.
Ça c'est pareil.
Ça ce sont des préservatifs.
L'expérience des voyages précédents
nous a enseigné
que quand on traversait les villages
et qu'on s'arrêtait
dans certains dispensaires,
les étagères étaient vides.
On préfère s'adresser
aux dispensaires.
Parce qu'on sait que les médicaments
ne sont pas commercialisés à l'unité,
qu'ils seront utilisés
par les personnels médicaux
directement
à ceux qui en ont besoin
et ceux qui soufrent,
si ça peut les soulager.
La majorité de ces médicaments
sont des analgésiques,
c'est pour soulager la douleur
et puis d'autres un peu plus spécifiques,
mais c'est pareil.
Ils utiliseront certainement la notice
pour utiliser à bon escient
ce qu'il y a
dans toutes ces boîtes.
Au dispensaire Aimé Claire
poursuit ses consultations.
Les patients viennent
des villages alentour,
parcourant parfois
des kilomètres à pied en plein soleil.
Le dispensaire est ouvert depuis 1999
et nous sommes trois agents.
L'infirmier chef de poste,
l'AIS Agent Itinérant de Santé,
plus l'accoucheuse auxiliaire
pour 3422 habitants.
La plupart des patients
qui viennent souffrent du paludisme.
Après avoir fini de l'examiner,
on prélève un peu
de son sang pour faire le test.
S'il s'agit du paludisme,
on le traite sur place.
Malheureusement c'est en rupture.
Il y a les produits du paludisme
qui sont subventionnés.
Avec 500 francs,
elle peut se soigner du Paludisme.
La consultation
ne coûte que 100 francs.
Les médicaments du dispensaire
sont proposés à l'unité
et ils sont normalement contrôlés
et donc conformes.
Ce qui est loin d'être le cas
sur les marchés
où des vendeurs à la sauvette proposent
souvent de dangereuses contrefaçons.
Là se trouve
la salle de mise en observation.
Ici, on garde les malades.
On a une patiente souffrant
du paludisme grave qu'on a hospitalisé.
On a placé
une perfusion avec la quinine.
Présentement,
la quinine est finie.
Là, c'est du sérum salé qu'on a placé
pour maintenir la voie.
Il y a toute sa famille
qui est là pour la soutenir.
On a déjà reçu
les visites des touristes.
Ils sont venus
nous donner des produits
et c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on reçoit des touristes.
La plupart sont des anti-inflammatoires
pour soulager la douleur.
Ça nous va
vraiment droit au cœur.
On souhaiterait que les touristes
donnent les produits aux agents de santé.
Quand la population reçoit ça directement,
c'est très dangereux.
Ils peuvent s'intoxiquer
et avoir d'autres problèmes après.
Dans l'avenir,
on souhaiterait avoir plus d'agents
parce que
plus il y a de patients,
plus le nombre d'agents
devrait augmenter.
Gaoual est une bourgade dont les habitants
vivent loin de la capitale.
L'activité
est en partie assurée
par les petits agriculteurs qui viennent
vendre les produits de leur terre.
Très peu de touristes
viennent jusque Gaoual.
La piste n'a pas
ménagé le minibus du groupe.
Elle l'a tellement secoué
qu'il est hors service
pour le moment, car en Afrique, aucune
mécanique ne rend définitivement l'âme.
On a le support
de l'alternateur qui est cassé,
ce qui a affecté la courroie.
Tout à l'heure je vais aller chercher un
mécanicien puisqu'on est près de Gaoual.
On va dépanner ça
d'ici deux heures.
Ce sont les aléas
d'un circuit routier.
Tandis que Moumouni et son équipe
s'occupent de la bonne santé du minibus,
le groupe part en randonnée
vers le village D'aubirey
accompagné de bébé,
le guide Lobi qui les a rejoints.
Ce village est celui
du roi des Gan,
l'un des cinq souverains
officiellement reconnus par l'État.
Sa Majesté est en charge
de 11 000 sujets qui le respectent.
Il leur doit assistant ce qu'il fait dans
ce village en hébergeant les plus démunis.
Merci beaucoup.
Le jeune souverain n'est pas insensible
aux rencontres avec les voyageurs.
Ça nous permet d'échanger,
de se connaître,
de connaître la culture
des uns et des autres.
En tant que garant de la continuité
des traditions, ça me réconforte.
Quand les touristes passent,
il faut vraiment bien les accueillir.
Je me dis que le tourisme est bien
et ça permet de lutter contre la pauvreté.
Jean-Pierre et Dany distribuent
des présents apportés spécialement.
Visiblement, il n'est pas facile
de gérer le succès de ses actions.
Donne aux tous petits.
Venue d'on ne sait ou des mécaniciens
armés d'un poste à souder,
ont rejoint
Moumouni et Alassane.
Le carter d'alternateur
a rendu l'âme.
La réparation prendra plus
de temps que prévu.
Il faut improviser
un campement sur place
et espérer que
la réparation sera possible.
Dans cette région
où les loisirs sont rares,
des étrangers en panne
sont un spectacle en soi.
Il attire de jeunes curieux
venus du village tout proche.
Ça fait huit heures que Moumouni
et son équipe opèrent le minibus.
Il ne reste plus qu'à remonter
et espérer que le moteur reparte.
Après tant d'efforts portés par
le chant des enfants, le moteur repart.
Un instant magique,
tout le monde peut enfin aller se coucher.
Ce qui me fait mal au cœur,
c'est cette misère.
Les gens sont gentils,
accueillants et sont tristes.
Juste un bonjour arrive à les faire
sourire et qu'ils te fassent un signe.
Il faut aller vers eux,
sinon ils sont plutôt en retrait.
C'est parce qu'ils sont fiers.
Peut-être ils sont fiers ou tristes,
je ne comprends pas.
Je pense
que c'est de la fierté.
C'est de l'intelligence
et non de la fierté.
Ils sont fiers
de ce qu'ils sont.
C'est une forme
d'intelligence.
Ou de respect.
Lorsque tu donnes quelque chose
sans rien dire,
tu as l'impression
qu'ils font de l'aumône.
Par contre quand tu y vas,
tu discutes avec eux
et que tu leur apportes des choses,
c'est comme un cadeau entre amis.
Tu ne jettes pas un billet
ou quelque chose comme ça.
Il faut qu'ils sentent qu'il y ait
un certain rapprochement.
Comme les gens dans les villages
ne parlent pas français,
c'est difficile de s'approcher d'eux
et de discuter.
Ils le veulent bien,
mais comme ils ne parlent pas la langue...
On arrive à se faire comprendre
entre gens intelligents.
En ce moment,
ils se réservent.
Ils veulent s'approcher mais
ils se disent qu'ils vont être rejetés.
Quand vous venez vers eux,
leurs sourires s'affichent.
Les gens se rapprochent.
- c'est ça.
Le minibus repart,
il remonte vers le nord,
passera par la ville de Léo
pour rejoindre
le village de Tiébélé.
Tiébélé est un village proche
de la frontière ghanéenne.
Il fait partie
du Pays des kassénas,
une ethnie qui s'est installée
depuis longtemps en territoire burkinabé.
Ses habitants vivent
de l'agriculture et de l'élevage.
En suivant quelques minutes l'unique route
de terre qui traverse Tiébélé,
on arrive à la cour royale.
Ce palais est décoré
selon l'art traditionnel kasséna,
entièrement réalisé
par les femmes du village.
Notre groupe se promène dans ce labyrinthe
décoré de formes géométriques
et de signes qui expriment la vie
des habitants de chaque maison.
Les habitants du palais
appartiennent tous à la famille royale
et la décoration de leur case
à une réputation internationale.
Les visites du palais et de nombreuses
autres initiatives sont assurées
par l'association
du développement de Tiébélé.
Michel Dansongo
est l'un des responsables.
Leur objectif est de redistribuer
l'argent gagné avec le tourisme.
C'est dans l'auberge de cette association
que notre groupe dormira.
Nous avons environ quinze personnes
qui travaillent dans l'auberge.
Nous avons quinze guides,
quatre cuisiniers et d'autres jeunes
qui travaillent dans l'auberge.
Ils font le nettoyage
et d'autres puisent de l'eau.
Environ 15 jeunes
qui travaillent dans l'auberge.
Les revenus de l'auberge,
c'est pour aider la femme
à faire le microcrédit dans les villages.
Nous avons remarqué que
les femmes aiment faire du commerce,
mais elles n'ont pas de moyens
d'aller à la caisse prendre un crédit.
Une partie des bénéfices est reversée
aux femmes qui décorent les maisons.
C'est un travail difficile.
À la base pour l'enduire,
elle mélange de la latérite,
de la bouse de vache et de l'eau.
Elles sont une trentaine
à savoir encore exprimer cet art
qui se transmet
de mère en fille.
Lorsque le soleil a séché les murs,
avec des peintures constituées
de charbon de bois, de craie pilées,
elles tracent des représentions d'outils,
d'ustensiles de la vie courante,
des armes
ou des animaux sacrés.
Ces décorations murales
servent de pièce d'identité à la case,
mais aussi de protection
contre les pluies.
Michelle souhaite
présenter l'une de ses fiertés.
Je vous présente
la bibliothèque de Bridanny.
À l'auberge,
la Chambre coûte 5000 francs
et dans les 5000, il y a 10% pour
le fonctionnement de la bibliothèque.
Les livres sont collectés en France,
ça vient de l'association Bridany
basée en France.
Elle collecte les livres
et les envoie chaque année.
C'est pendant les récréations
que les élèves viennent pour lire,
de 14 heures à 15 heures
les jeudis et les samedis.
C'est un plaisir pour moi
d'avoir mes enfants
ou mes petits frères
qui arrivent à lire
pour améliorer leurs études.
C'est un honneur pour moi.
Le minibus s'engage
sur la route du retour vers Ouagadougou.
Il y a plus de dix jours
que le groupe est parti.
Avant de rejoindre la capitale,
il doit s'arrêter pour une dernière halte.
Un lieu à la fois étrange,
inquiétant,
mais qui est devenu
un exemple concret de réussite solidaire.
Les habitants de Bazoulé vénèrent
un animal inquiétant et dangereux.
Ils ont compris que les touristes
étaient attirés par les sensations fortes.
Ainsi est née l'idée d'en tirer profit
pour le bien de la population du village.
L'entente cordiale entre les villageois et
crocodiles garantit aux deux populations
crocodiles et humaines,
une amélioration de leur qualité de vie.
Seule concession nécessaire
satisfaire la curiosité.
Alphonse Kaboré, comme tous les enfants
du village, a grandi avec les crocodiles.
Non seulement il n'en a plus peur,
mais il les respecte
et il est certain
que c'est réciproque.
Il a 30 ans.
Il est à l'origine du projet
de développement équitable de Bazoulé.
Le projet est né depuis 1999.
C'est en 1999 qu'on a eu l'idée
de créer l'association
Tourisme et développement
de Bazoulé.
Les touristes venaient visiter seulement
avec les guides de la capitale,
mais ça ne payait pas
car les visites étaient gratuites.
Les jeunes ont eu l'idée
de s'organiser
pour qu'avec
l'argent qu'on recueille,
on peut initier des micros-activités
pour développer le village.
Au début on était sept.
Aujourd'hui, on est plus de 42 jeunes
qui travaillent dans le projet global.
Depuis mon enfance,
j'ai vécu avec les crocodiles ici,
donc je n'ai plus peur d'eux.
Au début ça faisait peur,
mais plus maintenant, il y a la confiance.
Les enfants du village
se baignent dans la mare.
Pendant la période
des nénuphars,
ils plongent pour l'enlever
parce qu'on les mange.
Les crocodiles savent maintenant
qu'il ne faut pas attaquer les gens
ni même les animaux
qui viennent boire.
Il y a une cohabitation directe
entre la population et les crocodiles.
En mars, avril quand l'eau fini,
il reste seulement de la boue.
Là, les femelles attaquent les mâles
parce qu'il mangent les petits.
C'est la loi de la nature.
Les mâles quittent la mare
et se réfugient chez les familles à côté.
Tu peux te lever le matin, trouvé qu'il
y a trois crocodiles dans le poulailler
ou sous le grenier.
Ils sont inoffensifs.
Les femmes versent de l'eau sur eux
pour les mouiller
parce qu'ils sont venus
se caser là-bas.
Le chef de famille trouve
des poulets pour les nourrir.
Ça fait l'honneur
de la famille.
Quand le crocodile repart dans la mare,
ça fait une fête pour la famille.
Ici,
c'est l'école la case du savoir.
En moré
ça s'appelle bangré zaka.
On a eu l'idée de créer cette école
parce que c'est lié au tourisme.
On a constaté que
depuis qu'on a créé le projet,
des enfants viennent parce qu'il y a
des touristes tout le temps.
Il ne faut pas qu'ils
deviennent des mendiants.
Il y a beaucoup d'enfants qui n'ont pas eu
la chance d'aller à l'école.
Comme ils n'ont pas eu cette chance
ils suivent les blancs.
On s'est dit c'est mieux de
créer l'école
pour les donner
une seconde chance
et permettre aussi à ceux qui veulent
faire quelque choses,
par exemple
au niveau des métiers.
Ils peuvent apprendre à sculpter,
à élever, à faire le maraîchère.
Ils peuvent apprendre
tout métier ici.
C'était ça l'idée au début.
En 2003,
on a lancé la première classe.
Actuellement, on en a quatre,
avec plus d'une centaine d'apprenants.
L'objectif est atteint.
Parce que les enfants
qui venaient sur le site demander
de l'argent aux touristes,
c'est fini !
La démonstration que,
si les projets de tourisme impliqués
sont menés sérieusement,
les résultats sont à la hauteur
des espérances et des besoins.
Besoins qu'ont
les populations les plus fragiles,
les femmes et plus souvent
encore les enfants.
Les soutiens sont rares,
mais lorsqu'un projet comme fonctionne,
il attire les convoitises.
On a déjà commencé
à faire des démarches pour ça.
On a introduit une demande au ministère
de l'Environnement et du Cadre de vie
pour que la zone soit protégée
officiellement.
On aura vraiment l'assurance que les
crocodiles seront protégés dans l'avenir.
Quand viendra les lotissements,
on ne pourra pas toucher à cette zone-là.
Ça peut être dénaturé si on ne prend pas
des mesures pour la protéger.
C'est le dernier après-midi, le dernier
repas avant de quitter l'Afrique.
Bon appétit.
Comme toujours,
des enfants venus des villages voisins
ou de nulle part rejoignent le groupe.
Comme toujours lors de ce voyage,
les repas ont été partagés.
Pour ce dernier pique-nique,
tout sera mangé.
Ils ne doit rien rester, ils ne veulent
rien gâcher, tout distribué.
Le retour
en ville est un choc.
Il les rapproche du départ,
encore quelques mains serrées,
quelques sourires.
Pour quelques instants encore,
deux mondes si proches
et si différents se côtoient.
En attendant le vol de nuit
pour l'Europe,
le groupe passe
un dernier moment à table.
Un instant propice aux confidences
et aux émotions de fin de voyage.
Il est sûr que je garderai longtemps
en mémoire
une dame qu'on a été voir dans son
village qui ne voit jamais personne.
Alassane, notre cuisinier,
nous a indiqué un village
caché derrière le campement
où les enfants ne venaient pas le soir
nous voir autour du feu
comme d'autres enfants.
On y est allé le lendemain matin,
leur apporter des vêtements,
et des petites choses.
La grand-mère avait les yeux collés,
abîmés.
On avait des lingettes,
on lui a nettoyé les yeux,
on lui a mis de la crème.
Elle a pleuré
en nous tenant dans les bras.
On est repartis avec les frissons,
c'était épouvantable.
Je l'aurais dans ma tête
pendant longtemps.
Si on pouvait venir plus souvent
leur apporter encore plus de choses,
donner aux enfants,
les aider au maximum, on le ferait.
Ça nous touche énormément
De voir des petits dans la misère,
avec des haillons sur le dos,
qui mangent
qu'une seule fois par jour,
devant cette misère, ça me touche
beaucoup et je l'aurais dans la tête.
Mon mari ne sait pas
s'il arrivera à revenir,
tellement ça le retourne.
Ce qui me m'émeut toujours,
nous qui sommes des nantis
et des privilégiés,
c'est la pauvreté.
Chez nous
la pauvreté se cache.
Ici, non, parce qu'elle
est très authentique,
C'est affreux ce que je vais dire,
mais elle est presque naturelle.
Ils ne demandent pas
certainement à vivre.
Pour le moment
comme chez nous,
on est à des années-lumière de ce qu'on
a traversé pour arriver à notre condition.
Eux, simplement par des petites choses qui
se transcrivent par des regards,
par des sourires,
des touchés de mains,
des choses comme ça,
ça, ça m'émeut.